i'm brian kilmeade i'm martha mccallum
i'm david asman and this is the fox news
rundown
wednesday march 24th 2021
i'm dave anthony democrats long claimed
former president trump was trying to
steal an election
now republicans allege house speaker
nancy pelosi
is trying to steal a seat with so many
questions about election integrity how
are people supposed to believe that
their votes count in elections
if whoever the majority party is in
congress can just overturn the results
of elections that don't work out in
their favor
i'm jessica rosenthal after two
shootings in one week the president is
calling for new gun legislation
the background check system was created
27 years ago and we've had no update to
this
but for others the proposed laws go down
the wrong path
you get rid of the ar you don't think
there's going to be things out there
that are just as deadly and just as
accessible of course there are
and i'm kt mcfarland i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
congresswoman marionette miller meeks is
only two and a half months into her
first term
but there is a push to kick her out of
the house
the democrat she beat in november isn't
giving up yet
they skipped over the iowa courts
because they thought they would lose
miller meek's margin of victory was just
six votes but rita hart contends
she won because some ballots were not
counted
and she has gone to the democrat-led
house which by law could overturn the
result
and give heart the seat it's happened
three times dating back to the 1930s
they would disenfranchise four hundred
thousand iowa voters
in order to get the results they need
congresswoman miller meeks
insists everybody should be outraged
about this because it may be iowa two
this year but it could be another uh
congressional seat in another year
but democratic congressman david price
tells fox
hold on well i wouldn't talk about
overriding i would talk about a lawful
process that the house administration
committee has
underway and we'll just have to see what
that
process produces the committee itself
can't make the change
if it recommends heart take the seat the
full house would have to approve that
and at least one democrat congressman
dean phillips says he'd vote against
removing miller meeks
another new congresswoman from iowa is
going to bat for her colleague
the situation is it's very uncertain at
this point but the votes for
marionette miller meeks my fellow
congresswoman here from iowa were they
were counted
they were recounted here in iowa and
then they were certified by a bipartisan
board
ashley hinson represents iowa's first
house district
the number one thing i've been hearing
from my constituents and other islands
is
that they're just outraged that the
speaker pelosi is moving forward at this
point
to try to overturn the will of iowa
voters and
election results that were certified
here by the state and so what i did was
i led a letter of over 100 of my house
and senate colleagues
to the speaker on behalf of iowans and
americans who are angered by this
it's hypocritical of nancy pelosi to
support investigation into this
free and fair election while at the same
time she's saying voter fraud doesn't
exist across the country so
we're standing up we don't believe six
democrats on the house administration
could admit he should be able to
overturn six votes that were cast by
iowans that were
the deciding difference in this race the
issue
from what i understand in this race the
democrat who is challenging marionette
miller meeks rita hart
alleges that there were 22 ballots that
should have been counted
and they weren't if they had been
she would have won by nine votes instead
she lost
by six and so she's taking it to the
house administration committee
and they say it's a lawful process for
the house to review
why can't she do that well i think it's
very clear that these ballots didn't
meet the muster of state law
and that's why they were not counted in
the recount process
a judge ruled um you know as they were
going through this whole recount process
several months ago that those
did not meet the requirement and i'm not
exactly sure if every single one of them
was the same in terms of the requirement
but
you know we have laws about when those
ballots have to be received how they
have to be postmarked
and if ballots don't meet those
requirements um then
they're not counted or they're not a
valid ballot and so our bipartisan board
as i mentioned in the state certified
that election
after those recounts happened and they
determined if that marionette won by six
votes so
i think this is a terrible precedent to
set going around the will of iowa voters
and the court process here in iowa and
iowa law
ultimately states have the purview over
their elections and
um at this point i think you know with
so many questions about election
integrity how are people supposed to
believe that their votes count in
elections
if whoever the majority party is in
congress can just overturn the results
of elections that don't work out in
their favor and so
that's why we're pushing this um to make
sure that
um they know that here in iowa we run
safe and secure elections
and our state has not indicated that it
has questions about what happened in
november so
this election was certified and it
should stand and nancy pelosi should not
try to steal this seat
have you talked to any of the 10
republicans in the house who voted to
impeach president trump for inciting the
deadly capital attack
but have come out on your side on this
issue and saying
that they are being consistent that
that they're they they can't be opposed
to what happened then
and then before what's happening now
well i think uh the impeachment vote is
separate of what happened here with this
certification of a state election and i
think i would point to in general at the
at the start of session every member i
believe of congress maybe save one
voted to certify uh their own election
to congress and so
um to me the argument here is no matter
whether it's republicans or democrats
it's it's hypocrisy to say uh that you
certify your own election
nancy pelosi even sent a letter to
marionette saying
congratulations on your election to
congress welcome to congress
and um so i think it's about the
hypocrisy here regardless if you're
republican or democrat and we're
starting to see democrats come out
and say that just because you can do
this doesn't mean you should um and i do
think again this is about hypocrisy and
setting a terrible president president
well i mean guess to be devil's advocate
democrats could say that republicans
tried to undo
an electoral college certification
ballots that were certified by all 50
states correct
well i would say some probably did but
ultimately when i look at
i've been remarkably consistent on this
issue because i believe that we have to
follow the constitution
and that was true with the presidential
election that's true with this election
the state of iowa
counted recounted and certified these
votes and it's my job in congress
uh to make sure that we we follow the
the constitution which
allows states to have purview over their
own elections now we switch
to an issue that dates back to last
spring when covid closed schools
some are still not open again here's
congresswoman henson the other day
on the house floor the science on this
is definitive
if certain safety precautions are taken
teachers and students
can resume in-person learning safely and
she is advocating legislation to push
schools to bring kids back congress has
sent literally billions of dollars
out to schools across the country to get
schools back
open students and teachers can be back
in the classroom safely
and we are experiencing in this country
an academic crisis and a mental health
crisis
child depression rates are up youth
suicide rates are up
um the mental health toll on our
students is too high parents
needs a certainty as well um so what i'm
advocating for
is let's get these kids back in the
classroom across the country iowa has
done it safely so we're a great model
for how you can do that and provide
an in-person learning option but what we
need is accountability
we've got again 54 billion dollars that
went out in december
to get schools back open and another
almost 130 billion in the most recent um
stimulus package that just went through
so that money is designed to help go get
schools open and we need the
accountability there but they actually
have a plan
and they actually go through with that
plan to get kids back in the classroom
so you would have specific rules for
states communities how would it work
right so
what we were advocating for is that we
kind of divide the money up into thirds
a third of the money would go out the
door to schools right away
the cash infusion that they need to get
their plans up and running
but the other two thirds of the money
would be contingent upon
actually developing a plan to get reopen
and provide
an in-person learning option fifty
percent of students fifty percent of the
time
uh and then actually getting that plan
to a governor and then going through and
opening up
so it was truly designed to be a program
implemented by the state
to actually get these dollars to
classrooms and get those kids back
in classrooms safely so we just wanted
some accountability
with the money that's going out because
we're talking about billions of dollars
here and
thousands of students that are falling
off the grid now entering a second year
without being in a classroom
the longer the kids are out of the
classroom um the more unacceptable it
becomes
both the mental health challenges and
the longer parents are having to balance
work with homeschooling it's a huge
crisis for our country and a huge
challenge for our students
you several months ago tested positive
for the coronavirus
was your case mild yes i was incredibly
lucky i
i had a very mild case just a little bit
of i would call it exhaustion
um and and a little mild taste loft but
i bounced back very quickly
um but i you know i think what was
impactful to me
in in experiencing kobit myself was
you know our family has been through
several quarantines in the last year
i know what that impact has on a family
and i also know what it is like to
experience the virus my husband also had
it um
and at the same time so yeah we've been
through it and
that's why i'm trying to advocate to get
as much vaccine out in the state of iowa
as possible so we can get
back to normal as quickly as possible
the next big thing
in congress could be even bigger
than the nearly two trillion dollar
covert financial aid bill
an infrastructure package president
biden's working with democrats on
that could be worth three trillion
congressman ro
connor tells fox he wants to actually
invest
in job creation in artificial
intelligence and clean energy and
quantum computing and synthetic biology
to out compete with china democrats also
might try to include
free college tuition for some universal
pre-kindergarten education and paid
family leave senate republican leader
mitch mcconnell warns
it may actually be a trojan horse for
massive tax hikes and other job-killing
left-wing policies now infrastructure
improvements
are important to congresswoman henson i
think the number one priority for me is
i want to make sure small states like
iowa
are not forgotten in a big
infrastructure package
we have a lock and dam system that's
vulnerable and needs upgrades
to make sure that our agricultural
products can get to market
you know the mississippi obviously is a
huge part of our river economy here in
iowa and
many other states um up and down the
mississippi so um
i just want to make sure that iowa isn't
forgotten in any of these big packages
that we're talking about
um we haven't seen an official proposal
yet at the committee level but um
priorities for me in infrastructure are
not just the roads and bridges but
like i said the lock and dam system and
then also um i think
it is really important to have the
conversation about broadband
infrastructure as well and how that fits
in so
i'm hoping that all those things can be
part of of this package discussion
i was touring a local mental health
access center
and they're focusing they have a whole
room devoted to telehealth
you need broadband to be able to do
telehealth and so
those are issues that i see as very
pressing for our country and i'm hopeful
that whatever package is worked on
includes provisions like that that are
beneficial to iowa
obviously there's a lot of partisanship
involved in this though because you have
republicans
fearing that it's going to be too big
and tax hikes are going to be part of
the deal
right and that is a concern i mean i
think we have to be cognizant of
how much money we're spending that's why
you saw
you know many members of our conference
step up against what we perceive to be
wasteful spending in that last
uh coven 19 supposed relief package
because there was a lot of spending in
there that was not related to the
pandemic
i would rather see if we're going to be
making those decisions spending
decisions that we go through the right
channels we actually have committee
discussions about them both parties
get input and we're able to move forward
on a package that's the best thing for
the american people
so i'm still hopeful that we'll be able
to move forward in that direction
our appropriations committee um you know
we we are cordially working together
i'm seeing that every day so i'm i'm
definitely hopeful that we'll be able to
do that going forward
will you support any tax increases if
if it's in the proposal i don't support
tax increases right now i think that is
uh this is not the time to be pulling
the rug out from anyone
if anything i think we need to be giving
people long-term tax certainty
i'm hearing from people right now
they're concerned they don't want to
make investments they they don't want to
um to make those investments long-term
because they don't know what is ahead
and i think that's
that's a scary thing for our country and
for our economy right now coming out of
a pandemic
um i'll be looking at it very closely
because i don't think we should be
raising taxes on the american people
right now
congresswoman ashley henson republican
from iowa thank you very much for
joining us
thank you dave for having me i
appreciate the chance to talk with you
[Music]
this is kt mcfarland with your fox news
commentary
coming up president biden ordered flags
at half-staff for the 10 victims in the
boulder colorado supermarket shooting
each of the victims names was announced
at a press conference tuesday
headed by boulder police chief maris
harold to have something like this
happen so
so close to where you live and
and to know the fear in the community
and to know that the officers sacrifice
themselves
it's heartbreaking a 21-year-old from
arvada colorado has been arrested and
charged with 10 counts of murder for the
shooting at a king super's grocery store
but in washington the conversation
pivoted to guns during remarks at the
white house tuesday
president biden acknowledged the victims
and said it's time for additional gun
legislation
urging the house and senate to act we
can ban
assault weapons and high-capacity
magazines in this country
once again i got that done when i was a
senator
it passed it was law for the longest
time
and it brought down these mass killings
we should do it again
we can close the loopholes on our
background check system
he noted that the house just passed
legislation expanding background checks
and giving the fbi more time to vet
potential buyers but getting 60 votes in
the senate to get those house bills to a
vote
seems unlikely per republicans the
senate judiciary committee had a hearing
on gun violence tuesday it was scheduled
before the shootings in atlanta and
boulder
illinois democratic senator dick durbin
asked senators to act
we won't solve this crisis with just
prosecutions after funerals
we need prevention before shooting but
republican texas senator ted cruz
said the kind of legislation being
proposed would have done nothing to stop
many of the mass shootings
he said he and another republican
senator have better solutions
senator grassley and i together
introduced legislation grassley cruz
targeted at violent criminals targeted
at felons targeted at fugitives
targeted at those with serious mental
disease
to stop them from getting firearms to
put them in prison when they try to
illegally buy guns
but again the question is is now the
time new legislation will pass
with the house senate and white house
dominated by democrats
we as a gun violence prevention movement
know that the american people have
spoken
on these issues over and over
and over again chris brown is the
president of brady united which calls
itself a gun violence prevention
organization
in every major campaign that's happened
in the last several years we want change
and if the senate can't bring
hr8 or h.r 1446 the two bills to
to close gaps in the background check
system
that were created over the last 27 years
just to be clear
the background check system was created
27 years ago and we've had no
update to this if we can't pass these
measures
that 90 plus percent of americans
believe need to be in place in the u.s
senate
if 60 of the u.s senate can't do that
then we need to end the filibuster the
time is now because
literally if that can't happen it means
people are dying in this country
because of this filibuster yeah let me
ask you
let's drill down on that because
democrats are in charge now you would
think they could get something done
in the vein of what you want um you know
but they do need that
those 60 votes and we have heard um from
republicans that they feel the
these house bills are too expansive for
them i
imagine you've you or your members of
your organization have actually spoken
with republican senators
what is your understanding of what of
what could pass what would they go for
if not these bills the kinds of issues
that are raised with me
around these bills honestly leave me a
little incredulous
it's things like i'm concerned about the
ability
for individuals to transfer guns
inter-familial
a grandfather to a grandson or a parent
to a child all of those exceptions are
put in
to this measure either you can do it
in intestate through your will
and that will pass down and it's fully
allowed by hr8
or out of safety all you have to do is
go to a local gun dealer
and finalize a transaction and conduct a
background check
either way these are the kinds of things
that are done
every day across this country in
communities across this country
without any issue so when i hear
legislators
claiming that hr 8 would somehow
interfere with families passing down
guns over the generations or a mother
giving a gun to her son or child
that's already been covered in this bill
so it's hard for me to imagine that that
is much
more than a talking point that i have
heard
over and over again for the last 40
years
let me ask you chris um this i know this
is a bit of a sensitive question but
so many of the mass shootings when you
look at them
it turns out the people who got the gun
would not necessarily have been stopped
by a background check
or they passed the background check you
know many of them are younger they don't
have criminal records there is no
red flag let's say you succeed
let's say you get your you know expanded
background check legislation let's say
all the things you want
happen um in in many cases people will
still get firearms if they want them and
go on to commit
crimes with them and go on to use them
for nefarious purposes or commit mass
shootings as i just said
so many of these stories we find out
later that the person easily passed the
background check or never
you know never had a problem um you know
never had that red flag so what what do
you say in those instances
so the way this works is not
looking at a particular incident and
saying what law could have prevented
this
and saying okay we need to pass that law
it's saying what laws in conjunction
can save the most people and i can tell
you
with brady being in effect for 40 years
and talking to people and having friends
who survived
the harvest festival who survived aurora
who survive virginia tech they want
a comprehensive solution and whether
any of those things could have saved
them or not
is immaterial they want this to be
addressed
as a public health issue and they are
certain
as am i as our victims across this
country
that if we do that and invest in that
which we can tomorrow without
a single person being denied
the right to access buy and
carry a gun as they wish who's not
prohibited for some other reason
we can save many lives in this country
and end an epidemic of gun violence that
is
a uniquely american problem
but some second amendment supporters
believe the end goal with gun laws
including the two most recently passed
in the house is to slowly move to a
place where americans guns
are taken away retired staff sergeant
johnny joey jones is the host of fox
nation outdoors
and a fox news contributor i think that
nancy pelosi knows that she doesn't have
a lot of support for a
broad gun bill right now in the senate
and really doesn't have a large one
in the house and so those not to talk
too long but those two bills
specifically
uh the first one when you talk about
broad and universal background checks
what they're talking about is doing away
with person-to-person transfer
which was originally kept out of the
next system
law that passed with nra support because
of family members and friends that go
hunting together stuff like that a big
part of the gun culture and community is
that you
buy and sell guns among your friends and
it's a community thing and that's a big
part of the culture
the second one 1446 they're calling it
the charleston
loophole bill but if you actually read
what happened with charleston
it would not have prevented what
happened in charleston that man used
that gun
33 days after he purchased it and this
bill would extend that three-day period
to a 20-day period what happened there
and the fbi has admitted it they dropped
the ball
they did not finalize his background
check and
if he were a law-abiding citizen and the
fbi did that to 100 million people
that'd be a problem
so that's why that sunset exists it's
interesting because the head of the
brady campaign was telling us that the
the person-to-person transfer at least
among family members is
protected it is to an extent and and i i
when i look at this bill i'll tell you
as a very much pro-gun guy
hr8 has more legs as a guy with no legs
than any gun bill i've seen simply
because
but what it tells me tactically and this
is obviously
looking at both these bills prior to the
to the past week's events
is that there was not a lot of appetite
among the american people or at least
the senate
to pass a big gun bill so even this bill
hr8
has two provisions one would be family
to family transfer and the other one
would be temporary
transfer to a friend on like a hunting
trip the problem is those things are so
hard to define and there and also
what do they prevent they don't prevent
anything they're punitive after the fact
and that's the problem
let's talk about what um you know pro 2a
folks
maybe would go for or support if we're
going to talk about changing gun laws
you know polling has shown americans
would be okay with some new legislation
especially pertaining to background
checks
then again there were 21 million
background checks done i think it was
in 2020 for gun purchases and the
national firearm trade association
estimated that eight million of those
were first-time
gun buyers i mean just referenced uh the
appetite
for for new laws you know what would to
a supporters go for if anything
here's the problem right if you're a
pro-gun person you feel like if you give
an inch they take a mile so what would
second amendment
supporters go for they would go for a
honest
legislature a democrat party that
doesn't
advocate for banning and confiscating
guns
on one hand and saying but we just want
to extend background checks on the other
there needs to be trust and if you if
you broke your trust and i don't know
how you do it today
then you look at gun laws and say okay
what isn't working that should be
working the nix is a great example
in the past year i've waited two minutes
two hours two days two weeks
and almost a month um and then obviously
that's an anecdote but all of those are
true i've waited days weeks almost a
month
and minutes with the same name same
background same everything
and that's that is the problem we don't
we don't grow our resources for
background checks as the
supply and demand grows and this is a
three year hump not a
one year hump the uh gun purchases have
been growing for multiple years
and the fbi or the nyx system can't keep
up with it and what we're saying is
show me you're serious by investing in
that and make that work efficiently and
then let's go from there
and if that got included to say like hr8
then you might have a conversation
johnny finally what is what's the
solution in your mind to
mass shootings you know we've had this
conversation before we we hear about
mental health we hear about
uh you know additional security at
locations we we know ted cruz and and
senator grassley they're
trying to come up with legislation that
you know addresses things differently
that that
you know addresses criminal activity
what is
the solution if anything well let me
propose something to you
during the first assault weapons ban all
right you had ted kaczynski
eric rudolph you had 911 you had timothy
mcveigh you had columbine actually that
was a shotgun and a pistol
and in 2007 you had the virginia tech
incident was for two pistols and pistols
specifically are semi-automatic guns
that have
the most protections under federal law
and supreme court decisions today so
it'd be very very difficult to ban those
and my point there being is i just don't
know that mass shootings
are the gun violence problem we should
be worried about is it something we
should worry about of course
but my point there is when we went and
we saw
bombings happening and terrorist attacks
happening we didn't prevent the methods
we prevented
the incidents and the people and we did
a really good job at it by investing in
federal resources
to sniff these out and and prohibit or
prevent them beforehand and
i would be down for legislation that
does just that so i think republicans do
themselves a disservice when they just
simply go mental health mental health
but if you had conversations on what
that means and how you would do it then
then we could go down that path and say
hey you probably have to give up
something here and give the federal
government a better look at you
but in doing so if you prevent these
things then that might be the best thing
to do
because if you just try to prohibit i
mean we are the country of innovation
and technology if you get rid of the ar
you don't think there's going to be
things out there that are just as deadly
and just as accessible of course there
are because we saw that in the 90s
so it's the idea that you're going to
get rid of an object or a material
and make the world safer in a country
that's free just does not that doesn't
fly
johnny joey jones thank you so much for
your time absolutely thank you
from the fox news podcasts network i'm
ben dominic publisher of the federalists
and i'm inviting you to join a new
conversation with the smartest thinkers
out there about the country and where
we're going
subscribe to the ben dominic podcast
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcast.com
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
kt mcfarland
what's on your mind after the recent
high-level u.s china talks in alaska
there may be no going back china and the
us
are in a new cold war actually we've
been in one for years at least from
china's perspective
but now u.s leaders even some of the
woke socialists on the democrat left and
the biden administration they're waking
up to the threat china poses
to american peace and prosperity it's
unlikely any progress will be made on
the core
economic trade or human rights issues in
these or subsequent
u.s china negotiations why because
chinese communist party leaders believe
the tides of history have turned
the china is a rising power in the us a
declining power
that centralized authoritarian
governments are superior to
dysfunctional democracies
in short the chinese believe they are
already or soon will be
the strongest nation in the world any
concessions on major issues
will come from others not from china in
a way the chinese have done us a favor
they have put the new cold war out in
the open for all to see
but it is the last favor they will ever
give us
today china speaks openly about its
intentions the 21st century belongs to
them
and they plan to replace the united
states as the dominant world power
economically
technologically militarily politically
and diplomatically
and then rewrite the international rules
of order to suit their own interests
and at our expense if we are to preserve
the liberal world order democracy and
free markets for the 21st century
the u.s needs to come up with a new plan
to deal with
china just as we created a new world
order to deal with the soviet union and
communism
after world war ii we must now do the
same thing for dealing with china
and while history doesn't repeat itself
it does
rhyme at the end of world war ii the
world had two superpowers the united
states and the soviet union
the u.s reached out to the nations
devastated by the ravages of war
and through the marshall plan helped
rebuild their economies and societies
we did the same with our national
security needs creating and underwriting
a system of mutual defense alliances in
europe and asia
it worked brilliantly the biden
administration two of its credit has
begun exploring a new alliance between
the u.s
japan australia and india the quad the
question is how far are they willing to
take it
if it's merely an opportunity for the
four nations to collectively grouse
about
china the quad will do little to stop
china's push for dominance
without concrete action these are mere
words and aspirations
eventually the biden harris
administration will have no choice
but cave to china's demands however
if we can ban together with japan
australia india
and stand up to china and are willing
and able to work together
to deal with china's inevitable pushback
they
just might preserve the international
order from chinese domination
china's wolf warrior diplomacy is
already loose in asia and the world
they use their trade military and cyber
dominance to punish
any country that dares stand up to them
their plan is to pick us
off one at a time until only the u.s
remains isolated and alone
if president biden is unwilling or
unable to craft a security alliance
beginning with a quad
the next republican president will have
to do it in 2024.
i'm kt mcfarland and i was president
trump's first deputy national security
adviser
and i'm the author of the best selling
book revolution
trump washington and we the people
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network stay
on top of the latest news and
information from fox news
listen and download the fox news hourly
update on your time
the trending stories you need anytime
you want it listen and download now by
going to foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes